die lufa rim ist in deutschland ein
wirklich gefehlt hast da er spielt in
mehreren bands ist als solokünstler
unterwegs gewann 2017 auch die beliebte
show let's dance und wird auf instagram
für seine positive art von zahlreichen
fans gefeiert jetzt aber meldet sich der
sohn des israelischen sänger abi ofarim
der 2018 leider verstorben ist mit einem
ernsten video bei seinen followern auf
instagram er wurde nämlich in leipzig
opfer eines antisemitischen übergriffs
einen guten abend zusammen
ich weiß ich bin ja sprachlos ich weiß
nicht wie ich sagen soll
ich wurde in der vergangenheit oft
gefragt zum thema antisemitismus in
deutschland
ich bin jetzt gerade hier in leipzig in
einem hotel namens westen den namen des
managers am counter werde ich jetzt
nicht nennen das war ein herr t
und es ist eine riesige schlange weil
der hund computer download kann
passieren alles gut kann passieren aber
ich stehe hier mit man einer kette steht
mir zu
machen schon mal leben lang und eine
person nach der anderen wird vorgezogen
und ich verstehe nicht warum
irgendwie ohne scheiß 15 später komme
ich dran und frage mich schon was ist
los das ist nicht in ordnung warum
werden alle vorgezogen und sagt er
dieser herr w die schlange zu entzerren
ich stehe auch in der schlange
man ruft irgendeine aus der ecke packt
ein stern ein
mann sagte er wir
packen sie ihren stern ein
hamburg
und dann sagt er wenn ich bin jetzt ein
packen darf ich einchecken
[Musik]
wirklich
deutschland 20 21
der eine täter fehlen die worte
zugeschaltet ist der bild-reporter die
roben nußbaum vor ort nußbaum die roma
erste frage was sagt das hotel wie
rechtfertigt sich das hotel
das hotel hat sich noch gar nicht uns
gegenüber gerechtfertigt die anfrage
läuft dazu angeblich ist der
hoteldirektor der er das nicht muss dann
mitbekommen haben soll noch in einem
meeting was nicht länger zieht aber wir
haben mit dem management von bülow war
ihm schon kontakt gehabt offensichtlich
haben das schon sehr sehr viele leute
gesehen dieses video ist er knapp zwei
minuten lang und macht einfach nur
fassungslos was in dem motto gestern
abend hier passiert sein soll vielleicht
legt man sich schon ein statement zu
recht und möchte dann mit den richtigen
antworten auch sich zurück melden was
man dazu sagen kann ist ein luxushotel
in leipzig im zentrum nicht weit vom
hauptbahnhof entfernt mit über 400
zimmern die nacht kostet ab 200 euro
aufwärts und viele stars steigen hier ab
deswegen auch gelobt hat natürlich
darauf gewartet auch hier einen guten
gästeservice zu bekommen nur wenn sich
das gestern abend wirklich so abgespielt
haben soll dann macht es einfach nur
sprachlos
weißt du wo operieren verblieben ist wo
es ja dann untergekommen hast du kontakt
fehlen genau das natürlich nicht hier
geblieben in diesem hotel kurz darauf
hatte sich mit dem management in
verbindung gesetzt und man sagte uns
dass er sofort in einem anderen hotel in
leipzig untergebracht worden sei er war
hier für einen fernseh für eine neue
sendung die bald herauskommen soll mit
anderen promis unter anderem auch
jeanette biedermann war dabei
in welchem hotel er dann unter gekommen
ist wurde nicht gesagt auf jeden fall
ist er diese nacht doch in leipzig
geblieben und ist jetzt aber schon nicht
mehr in der stadt sondern auf dem weg
zum nächsten termin er möchte sich in
den nächsten minuten bei uns auch
zurückbleiben wird behördlich gegen das
hotel vorgegangen
das versucht man gerade noch zu klären
das management sagte mir dass man
natürlich mit den anwälten in
verbindungen sei und eine anzeige gegen
das hotel auch gibt jetzt handelt es
sich hierbei um einen davidstern wir
sehen uns ja auch im hintergrund kann es
sein dass diese symbolik vielleicht auch
missverstanden wurde von dem mann an der
rezeption
ich gehe nicht davon aus also leipzig
hat eine große jüdische gemeinde hier um
die ecke ist auch gleich eine synagoge
man kann schon etwas damit anfangen es
wurde gesagt dass das wort david stern
in den mund genommen nur packt einen
stern ein
ich gehe aber fest davon aus dass der
manager an der rezeption der ähnlich der
hoteldirektor war aber der manager an
der rezeption genau wusste um was es
sich handelt
unglaublicher vorgang wenn alles sich so
zugetragen hat
[Musik]